you welcome to this video mm-hmm and
bashes something now that's not going to
be right my try at pronouncing this
correctly should i do the bogo again and
maybe maybe the Queens gambit do
something different anyway disguise from
India so we get not an Indian opening
but a classical means gambit he takes on
f6 yeah the slide is somewhat um
somewhat out of fashion but not bad
quidsi too that's very sharp sorry so
that's coffee here yeah I'm trying to
open up the position as quickly as
possible against against them long
castling um always difficult to to judge
how you should play them if you have
home forgotten the actual lines it's
been a long time since I've looked at
this in any detail but black normally
has got some decent compensation in in
this kind of this kind of way I'm having
this excellent bishop and right again to
be typically quick decisions but Jen and
we'll see what happens I'm getting to
enter with the Queen and certainly have
some kind of compensation to have enough
compensation I don't know maybe but I
couldn't really figure everything out in
that brief brief time
okay so he wants to take and probably go
Bishop c4 yeah maybe yeah planet
checking at Queen 85 not sure
very sharp situation quite clearly yeah
here I have to recapture cannot omit c5
was protected by the night only six oh
wow that's a that's a tough move what
may be a good one maybe a good one ok I
can check but after Queen B 2 it's not
that great so probably this yeah so you
will wants to check there I have to go
knight c6 I'll guess checking before I
probably had to take
not sure I mean you play this like
instantly as they usually do in
supercritical position so tough to same
okay i'm checking only one I mean I
cannot trade Queens really yeah checking
checking looks right King see to 94 wins
the exchange with very unclear
consequences King moves here I don't
know if they move the King probably
Queen d4 check
it is the typical are typical is wrong
but a case where the somewhat
conservative Queens gambit declined led
to very sharply this is happening
actually more often than you would think
check if white is going for something
like this year with long castles it is
very sharp ok so now I can take you
forward chick and I know anything better
Queenie three year as a probably a good
reply hmm I can go up to eight rook
takes d4 it's not really threatened
chicks here after Queen III I don't know
what exactly my movers queen edge for
Bradley Queen g6 something like that he
still has stuff on the e-file this is
kind of tricky I don't know here on h4
difficult to be called the same yeah
rook e8 is my idea pinning all this on
the e-file
dad I know what you should do very very
tough okay eight
yeah I assume there should be something
good for white but I kind of really say
what it is maybe Luke t6 or something an
unknown it's not easy to play at all be
5v5 maybe be 595 I guess I know it's
taking very long time or is there some
some connection problem I don't know
check it's not me he's got a connection
issue ping is ping it's very long and
what a shame it is really interesting
position I don't know I really suspect
that he should have something but cannot
wait I don't really know what maybe be
five I mean it's maybe a way to try to
keep the initiative and I really don't
have that great squares probably 5.4
fits due to disconnection you know that
was really was a connection issue not
something out of frustration or so so
let's have a look there okay I went like
this and now I went Queen 85 m okay it
was dicey decision for sure yeah the
engine says that white is clearly better
here yep check possible possible you for
wishing sings night here
97 given a somewhat better check now
this is strong it really is strong c4
here and now I are there the engine is
giving this move interesting gather this
idea just trading stuff then like rook
g6 and white is Paula and has the better
game sorry for the noise it's my coffee
coffee maker check and this this cannot
be bad queen bee three maybe is bad i
don't know hmm engine gives queen bee to
check chat forum here to just eat steaks
and it was this was the position where
he disconnected the engine gives rookies
six ESS I've somehow expected like
covering this I go here and now calm
gives this and gives what a pawn plus
white should be better now he's really
is that pawn up and my king position is
still kind of in bad shape so yeah he
must be better there so i guess it was
lucky that you disconnected i mean the
position is so kind of murky I'm
threatening things like that but
ultimately it must be good for wide I
think I probably have to improve right
in the opening but I didn't want to as
it was pretty clear that this is one of
the guys who plays instant moves I
didn't want to spend much time in the
engine gives knight c6 is better for
example intending that before I think
this is this whole kind of play with
taking on f6 and canceling law leads to
very sharp in unclear play but not it
shouldn't be really good for
so um I certainly shouldn't be in
trouble as I was in the game but my
desire to play quickly probably am was
leading to a bad position not probably
it was a bad position okay well thanks
for watching